[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 6 janvier voici
les titres face à la recrudescence des
cas de covile 19 levac six bus du
département des yvelines reprennent leur
tournée ils sillonnent les routes du
territoire pour permettre la vaccination
du plus grand nombre joueurs
pontchartrain le père d'enis ville ou
encore les temps la ville sont les
prochaines étapes en 2022 nous célébrons
les 400 ans de la naissance de molière à
cette occasion la ville de versailles à
laquelle le dramaturge ailier prévoit un
programme spécial tout comme d'autres
communes yvelinoise le point à suivre
et puis pour la treizième année
consécutive le paris-nice passera par
les yvelines le parcours a été dévoilé
ce mercredi à l'hôtel du département à
versailles cette année la course au
soleil partira de mantes la ville pour
la première étape le 6 mars le lendemain
le peloton s'élancera d'auffargis
une boutique à l'essai à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines c'est la
solution trouvée pour redynamiser le
centre ville on en parle tout à l'heure
[Musique]
levac six bus ont repris du service
depuis le 2 décembre un dispositif lancé
en mars 2021 par le département des
yvelines en partenariat avec l' agence
régionale de santé l'objectif de cette
opération c'est de rendre encore plus
accessible la vaccination ce jeudi c'est
maxi bus ont fait étape à triel sur
seine et ablis mais la tournée continue
dans 29 autres communes du département
les précisions de justin brasier
[Musique]
oh
c'est exactement le même le même
cheminement à part que
il se fait en partie dans un ancien
camion puisque c'est le centre de
vaccination qui vient auprès de la
population mais c'est exactement le même
parcours avec un médecins des
infirmières et une attestation avec un
qr code qui est produit
[Musique]
et avec la déferlante du variant omicron
les entreprises mais aussi services font
face à de nombreuses absences de
personnel c'est le cas vous le voyez à
guyancourt pour les agents de la
restauration scolaire dans les
maternelles et élémentaires par
conséquent la ville demande aux parents
qui le peuvent de garder leurs enfants à
la maison le temps de la restauration
pour les journées de vendredi et lundi
au minimum sur les réseaux sociaux la
municipalité précise que les repas ne
seront pas facturés sur ces deux jours
les parents pourront d inscrire leurs
enfants sur le portail famille les
directeurs d'accueil et les atsem le
feront en cas d'oubli vous avez une idée
de commerce mais vous ne savez pas
comment la mettre en place à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines une boutique à
l'essai vient d'être installée elle
accueillera très bientôt un nouveau
commerce pendant six mois et ceux
renouvelable une fois l idée derrière
c'est d'aider les auto entrepreneurs
tout en redynamisant le centre ville le
reportage de céline charles après
bonnières sur seine et mantes-la-jolie
c'est au tour de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines d'inaugurer sa
première boutique à l'essai une boutique
de 37 mètres carrés qui propose à des
créateurs de tester leurs idées de
commerce au sein d'une boutique pilote
de six mois le premier axe est d'avoir
la commune
s'ils jouent le jeu le deuxième axe
boutique un local le troisième c'est
d'avoir un porteur de projet et puis le
quatrième c'est de l'accompagnement il
est aidé tout d'abord par pour voir si
son modèle d'affaires son business model
quand on parle anglais et pérenne est
pertinent par rapport à l'envol endroit
qu'ils souhaitent s'implanter senti
d'activité suite ya le loyer modéré la
modération des loyers de manière à ce
que la charge ne soit pas trop important
qu'initialement et puis troisième levier
c'est aussi le prêt à taux zéro les
prêts d'honneur un concept lancé par
initiative sa divine en lien avec
rambouillet territoire la municipalité
et le propriétaire nous souhaitons
vraiment qu'à donner une chance à un
nouveau commerçant à saint-arnoult qui
aurait peut-être des difficultés pour
prendre lui même à 100 quand on bouquine
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'ils soient elles
et dès avant de démarrer
je suis le premier voulant l'aider on
n'est pas au delà du soutien de
l'accompagnement aux porteurs de projets
elle permet également de redynamiser le
centre ville en créant de nouveaux
commerces de proximité cela contribue à
la redynamisation du centre-ville et
nous sommes vraiment
conscient que c'est un effort pour un
commerçant de s'installer et que c'était
des vraiment la bienvenue pour le
territoire nous voulons que que cette
boutique contribuer au dynamisme de
notre commune souvent la ville va dire
ben shepherd une mercerie tiens j'ai
besoin de 2,2 de friperie jeu voilà donc
on va pouvoir aussi orientés en fonction
des besoins de la ville alors si votre
projet correspond contacter initiative
saniclean les lauréats devrait être
choisi d'ici la fin du mois de janvier
[Musique]
722 2022 cette année ce sont les 400 ans
de la naissance de molière jean baptiste
poquelin était né le 15 janvier 16 122
et la ville de versailles va profiter de
cet événement pour célébrer le
dramaturge français au destin lié
forcément à la ville et son château
molière qui a été pendant longtemps le
protéger et de louis xiv françois de
mazières est avec nous par
visioconférence nos soir
vous êtes le maire de versailles et vous
avez créé d'ailleurs il ya 26 ans le
mois molière qui donc existe dans la
ville depuis longtemps il y aura
forcément aussi une programmation
particulière cette année on va en parler
dans un instant et déjà molière et et
versailles les liens qui existent entre
le dramaturge et la ville on pense
forcément déjà une pièce l'impromptu de
versailles qui a été créée en 763 dans
la demeure royale molière a aussi
collaboré avec lully lors des fêtes des
plaisirs de l'île enchantée sont les
premières grandes fêtes qui avait été
donnée en 764 par louis xiv dans les
jardins du château de versailles avec
des représentations théâtrales dont le
célèbre tartuffes qui a été jouée pour
la première fois molière à on peut le
dire a laissé marque durable dans la
ville oui molia c'est vraiment une
personnalité qui a asséché la ville de
versailles tout simplement parce que
versailles c'est aussi lui 14 et aussi
son ex travail un château et molière est
venu c'était un organisateur aussi de
fait assez exceptionnel
il est venu en 563 pour la première fois
en octobre ses 163 laufon c'était le
premier festival molière parce qu'il a
joué quatre de ses pièces noctum 563
donc la porte de versailles mais
pourquoi l'impromptu de versailles parce
que c'est effectivement une pièce qu'il
a écrite au très très peu de jo et il a
écrit pour versailles et c'est pour ça
que cette pièce est resté avec ce nom et
c'est est-ce particulier intéressant
parce que c'est monia qui se met en
scène lui-même avec des personnages qui
sont les rédacteurs de sa troupe et
molière ont fait répond à la critique
c'est la kabbale qui ait eu lieu sur
l'école de femmes une année auparavant
donc voilà était un type qui avait une
santé communication extraordinaire à
féliciter il a utilisé l'événement pour
faire parler lui est douce et un pointu
et trois autres pièces qu'il a joué et
comme vous le rappeliez injustement soit
164 il ya une grande manifestation qui a
lieu dans les jardins des plaisirs de
l'île enchantée alors elle n'est nommé
celle ci est l'histoire de molière et et
des spectacles et beaucoup liés aux
bosquets qui sont dans le jeu plutôt
qu'on peut encore découvrir aujourd'hui
pourquoi c'est important pour la ville
justement de s'associer à cet événement
à les 400 ans de la naissance de molière
pourquoi proposer une année spéciale
finalement à versailles
n'a écouté pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que je pense que molière
c'est la référence mais du théâtre
français et lorsqu'il ya 26 ans j'ai
créé festival molière c'était parce que
sinon s'imposer pour moi si on voulait
faire un festival l'estival populaire
tournée dans la population il était
naturel dans cette ville où il a vécu il
ya des vécu plusieurs semaines et qui
était naturel que l'on donne à notre
fiscales sont donc aujourd'hui avec un
spécial qui a pris beaucoup d'ampleur
comme ont fêté son 80e anniversaire
il était normal que
notre ville soit vraiment au premier
rang et pour être au premier rang j'ai
souhaité que l'exposition commence le 15
janvier et c'est la première exposition
qui aura lieu en france sur molière bien
avancé qui aura lieu plus tard à paris
à l'espace richard c'est le nom de cette
exposition c'est molière la fabrique
d'une gloire nationale
absolument parce que le commissaire de
cette exposition et martial poirson qui
est un universitaire spécialiste de
molière et universitaires parisiens de
la sorbonne et il vient de sortir un
livre pour cette exposition allez que
j'invite les passionnel volière à lire
extrêmement intéressant cette année qui
montre que depuis sa mort vous lire a
toujours été une référence quel que soit
le régime en france n'est d'ailleurs
même au delà de france mounir c'est une
personnalité qui par les prises de
positions qu'il a fait à travers ces
pièces a toujours été récupéré par
toutes les formes de régimes c'est
d'ailleurs sans doute assez unique dans
l'histoire de la littérature si l' on
voit que c'est un grand jenny est donc
cette exposition je le précise aura lieu
du 15 janvier au 17 avril je le disais à
l'espace richaud il sera aussi question
de molière pendant la labatt la biennale
d'architecturé de paysage qui avait
attiré deux cent mille visiteurs lors de
sa première édition en 2019 elle revient
on met de mai à juin dans la ville avec
notamment cet événement et
l'inauguration aussi d'une statue de
molière oeuvres de xavier veilhan dans
le jardin du nouvel office de tourisme
dites nous en plus l'oeuvre sera en
bronze je crois c'était l'occasion pour
nous les deux inaugurés une statue
consacré à l'eau hier cette statue de
consacrer à moliets sera réalisé par
un guy lion qui était un artiste
international très connu les alliés
peillon ancien a fait une grande
exposition au château de versailles
c'était la première personnalité qui
avait été invité par un chant jacques
aillagon et ils avaient été faits sont
ici en partie sous le thème des élus à
l'époque j'ai beaucoup intéressé les
élus s'étaient des personnages très
connus notamment de l'histoire de
l'architecturé et donc ayant vu cette
expédition je m'étais dit que c'était
l'artiste qu'il fallait pour réaliser
une stature de vierge était allé lui en
parler en ayant cherché et trouvé un
mécène financer cette oeuvre d'art et
xavier veilhan au départ madiot et je
n'ai pas beaucoup avoir un sujet comme
celle puis on a parlé de
l'ue s'attendent de chaussures ya celle
là on n'aurait pas sauvé et son l'idée
c'est d'utiliser comme modèle pour
réaliser son voeu la statue qui est très
célèbre qui a entré la commune i
française vous avez un molière est un
molière du avec une perception
romantique cette y en a été faite au 19e
siècle donc s'amollir un peu à
l'anguille qu'on connaît bien c'est
l'image qu'on voit beaucoup dans les
livres d'histoire les livres de jk
nature et donc ils veulent à
réinterpréter que sont complètement
contemporaine et cette statue sera placé
au coeur du premier dossier qu'on va
faire à l'intérieur de la ville de
versailles c'est quand je vous disais
tout à l'heure l'histoire de versailles
beaucoup liés aux bosquets qui sont dans
le parc du château cargo 14 points 3 ans
et 161 c'est un jeune roi ce qui lui
plaît c'est le petit relais de chasse
son père lui 13 qui attire lynch à ce
que nous devons encore en chant c'est au
milieu de l'actuel château de versailles
mais il y avait surtout
autour des jardins qui sont développés
et les premiers spectacles ont lieu dans
ces germain et donc ses bosquets c'est
quoi c'est une charmille végétal qui
protège a lieu l'intérêt aussi vu vous
avez toujours
la brouillard dont j'ai repris ce
concert c'est à dire que la sortie de la
gare dressel château il aura enfin ce
novice autorise que le voir réaliser qui
a été confiée à un architecte
contemporaine ses quatre filles qui ont
marre état et à côté et de cet office de
toulouse vous aurez ce premier bosquet
l'adversaire avec nos sens cette statue
qui va célébrer molière un homme dé
versailles et donc versailles qui va
célébrer molière toute l'année je le
disais aussi avec le mois molière toutes
les informations sur cette année
spéciale molière à versailles sur le
site internet est de la ville qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
françois de mazières d'avoir été avec
nous bonsoir merci beaucoup merci je le
rappelle maire de la ville de versailles
[Musique]
voilà pour cet entretien enregistré dans
la journée j'ai enfilé le masque car
c'est lié à get on go m'a rejoint en
plateau bonsoir ses liens au sein de la
rédaction de tv 78 de versailles mais
d'autres institutions aussi dans la
ville vont célébrer ses 400 ans de la
naissance de molière oui et ce n'est pas
n'importe quel établissement le château
de versailles compte bien lui aussi
célébré le dramaturge alors ce sera
précisément à l'opéra royal qui va
accueillir un cycle molière du 4 janvier
au 26 juin alors au programme trois
comédie ballet george dandin ou le mari
confondu le malade imaginaire ou encore
le bourgeois gentilhomme
des concerts sont également prévus
de toute façon vous pouvez retrouver le
programme complet sur le site
www.chateauversailles.fr tacle point fr
toujours à versailles d'ailleurs le
centre de musique baroque a créé une
expo de caste ses murs en mai en effet
une exposition sonore et visuel vous
attend et sur les sites du cndd il ya un
podcast en six épisodes qui est vraiment
un podcast qui nous guide dans les
musiques de molière delà de la jeunesse
de molière le rapport de molière avec la
musique et on va le conduire casino
voilà d'imaginaire justement jusqu'à sa
dernière pièce est entre-temps on va
balayer dans cette vie de molière tout
ce que molière va avoir commis avec la
musique il n'y a pas qu'à versailles
qu'on fêtera moyen de molière c'est ça
ce sera aussi également à saint germain
en laye jusqu'en juin prochain à la
commune présentera une exposition des
spectacles mais aussi aux des
conférences en associant et des acteurs
culturels locaux différents comme la
médiathèque le théâtre ou encore le
musée d'archéologie el nacional molière
on peut le dire avait un lien royal avec
une habile ya des liens étroits entre
molière et saint germain en laye à
l'époque de louis xiv n'a jamais était
la principale résidence royale c'est là
où le roi et la cour ces journées et
donc beaucoup des principales oeuvres de
molière ont d'abord été créée et jouée
pour la première fois à saint germain en
laye alors en ce qui concerne la
programmation le samedi 22 janvier sera
une journée dédiée à l'esprit aux
molières à la médiathèque marc ferro
avec des lectures et des spectacles
donnés par des élèves du conservatoire
claude dubut ci a de
saint-germain-en-laye surtout à ne pas
manquer merci célia pour toutes ces
précisions le rappel 2022 année du 400e
anniversaire de la naissance de molière
très exactement c'est le 15 janvier à 4
722 qui était né jean baptiste poquelin
dont 15 janvier 2022 400 ans de la
naissance de molière merci d'avoir été
avec nous sur ce plateau dans
l'actualité également cette polémique à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines une suspicion de triche
organisée aux examens de médecine c'est
nos confrères du figaro qui révèle
l'information la fraude se serait
déroulée ce mercredi lors d'un partiel à
distance de 300 étudiants de deuxième
année une majorité d'entre eux auraient
triché lors de ce qcm comment se
regroupant par groupes de deux ou trois
et en s'envoyant les réponses par mail
ou message c'est la moyenne très élevé
de cet examen et les erreurs aux mêmes
questions des groupes de groupe
important d'étudiants qui ont mis la
puce à l'oreille des examinateurs une
plainte a été déposée tout les partiels
annulé ils se dérouleront en présentiel
une enquête interne va être mené les
fraudeurs risquent des sanctions
disciplinaires du simple blâme à
l'exclusion définitive des études
médicales nous recevons d'ailleurs à ce
propos demain le professeur djillali
annane dans l'émission 7 8 week-end il
est le doyen de la faculté de médecine
de l'ubs est ce qu pour parler bien sûr
de ce sujet l'association yvelines
environnement lance son traditionnel jeu
concours tous les enfants et blinois de
3 à 15 ans pourront y participer jusqu'à
début avril le but les sensibiliser au
développement durable et notamment
osseux à ce thème choisi pour 2022 nos
amis pollinisateurs margot jésus au et
laura légaux
ce matin yvelines environnement réuni
ses partenaires pour annoncer le
lancement de son jeu concours pour
participer les enfants de 3 à 15 ans
devons remplir une grille de mots
croisés et réaliser un dessin avant le 6
avril l'association souhaite mettre en
avant le thème choisi cette année les
pollinisateurs
aujourd'hui tout ce qui tourne autour de
la pollinisation et de l'insecte
pollinisateur est extrêmement alarmant
puisque si nous ne pouvons pas si nous
ne prenons pas soin de nos insectes
pollinisateurs la pollinisation ne se
fera plus donc plus de fruits et donc
effectivement un problème pour pour
l'humanité entière le concours est
également proposée au sein des écoles
foyers d'hébergement et accueils de
loisirs yvelinois les professeurs et
éducateurs se serviront de ce jeu comme
support pour faire découvrir la nature
aux jeunes il est important de
reconnecter nos enfants à la nature par
quelques bien que ce soir alors si ce
jeu peut le permettre et bien c'est
extraordinaire les gagnants remporteront
des visites sur des thématiques
environnementales
la remise des prix aura lieu au palais
des congrès le 17 mai prochain
afin de selon elle voyait à nouveau mon
visage on va terminer avec du cyclisme
le parcours du paris nice 2022 a été
dévoilée ce mercredi à versailles comme
depuis 13 ans le coup d'envoi sera donné
une nouvelle fois dans le département
des yvelines cette année mantes-la-ville
et auffargis ont été retenue comme ville
départ pour accueillir les coureurs pour
cette 80e édition ce qu'il faut savoir
avec michael et demi d'euros et margot
jauzion c'est devenu une routine depuis
13 ans la conférence de presse du
paris-nice est programmée en janvier à
l'hôtel du département à versailles les
organisateurs dévoilent le parcours
officiel et à la fin deux communes d i
mean sondés ville départ une grande et
une petite ce 5 janvier ses manques la
ville vingt mille habitants qui a été
retenue pour lancer cette course au
soleil une boucle de 159,8 km à travers
les yvelines avec départ et arrivée
boulevard roger salengro le 6 mars on
est bien sûr très très très heureux on a
candidaté
et on a pu donc avoir cette cette
merveilleuse nouvelle de pouvoir être la
ville ont seulement l'étape mais
également donc de départ évidemment ça
va mettre en lumière notre notre commune
on est bien sûr très heureux le 7 mars
la deuxième étape partira de la petite
commune d'auffargis direction orléans le
village de 2000 habitants étaient
traversées à plusieurs reprises par le
tour de france et ce sera une nouvelle
fois un événement pour la commune ce
n'est pas la première fois que paris
nice passe dans le village mais c'est la
première fois qu'il y a des parts d'
étape de paris nice nous sommes ravis ça
va faire de l'animation un village qui
est déjà très animée mais ça va engager
aussi tous nos bénévoles qui sont là
toujours présent puisque c'est quand
même une belle organisation on a bien
aidé par esso mais c'est quand même une
grosse organisation pour un petit
village comme le nôtre cette 13ème
édition consécutive dans les yvelines
portera-t-elle chance à ces deux
communes libye noise réponse les 6 et 7
mars prochains
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité demain vendredi et place
aux 7,8 week-end de l'actualité et des
loisirs pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]